[Musique]
bonsoir et bienvenue dans ce nouveau
numéro du 7-8 débat ça n'a pas pu vous
échapper les prix du carburant ont
augmenté
face à cette hausse sensible du prix du
gasoil des automobilistes lance un appel
à bloquer les routes samedi une
opération relayée via les réseaux
sociaux qui semble prendre une ampleur
considérable des pétitions rassemble des
milliers de signatures pour cette
mobilisation samedi dit des gilet jaune
hausse des prix du carburant que fait le
gouvernement c'est le débat du jour avec
nous en plateau ce soir pour ans par
année daniel guerreau vous êtes
yvelinois et le président de
l'association 40 millions
d'automobilistes
bruno myle yens vous êtes député de la
9e circonscription des yvelines
bonsoir merci des tragiques bonjour bas
à trois jours de la mobilisation des
gilet jaune
edouard philippe a annoncé des mesures
d'accompagnement préparé par le
gouvernement face à la hausse des prix
du carburant notamment une augmentation
à la prime de la conversion jusqu'à 4000
euros pour 20 % des français les plus
modestes
actuellement elle a permis le renouveler
le renouvellement de plus de 220 mille
véhicules est néanmoins il ne permet pas
aux ménages les plus modestes de changer
de véhicule
autre mesure le chèque énergie
aujourd'hui à 150 euros il sera
augmentée de 50 euros
edouard philippe a également annoncé des
indemnités kilométriques élargi le
barème kilométrique sera réévaluée pour
tenir compte pour les ménages qui se
déplace beaucoup des coûts
supplémentaires liés à la hausse du prix
du pétrole
cette hausse du barème sera toutefois
concentrés sur les véhicules de faible
puissance pour ne pas envoyer un signal
contraire à la transition énergétique
que pensez vous de ces mesures évoquées
par edouard philippe
mais côté déjà le mouvement qui semble
avoir surpris le gouvernement ne nous a
pas surpris puisque tu es
mi septembre nous avons nous avons lancé
coup de pompe points comme parce qu'on
voyait monter le mécontentement des
automobilistes
on ne savait pas qu'elle commence à
l'espace et comment allait prendre ce
mouvement mais on voit qu'il est d'une
ampleur assez considérable quand vous
regardez tous les sondages c'est 80 %
des gens qui rejettent ces hausses alors
tout simplement pour vous dire pourquoi
parce que finalement on nous a vendu
cela comme un moyen de traiter le
problème écologique ou le climat
on a voulu nous faire comprendre que
finalement il suffisait d'augmenter les
taxes en france pour diminuer la
température de la terre
c'est quand même assez incroyable vous
regardez tous les prix du gazole dans
l'union européenne
eh bien vous avez trois ou quatre pays
légèrement au dessus et tout le reste
largement en dessous on voit bien que la
france à elle toute seule ne va pas
régler régler les problèmes de la
planète donc ce n'est pas compris en
réalité c'est pour boucler le budget de
l'état et ça tout le monde l'a bien
compris alors maintenant on nous annonce
un certain nombre de mesures les avaient
très bien je pense que là ça apparaît
aux autorités lui aussi tous les
témoignages qu'on a entendu aujourd'hui
dans les médias
personne n'est vraiment convaincu
puisque on al impression qu au nom d'une
espèce d' usine à gaz et qu'on va
distribuer 500 millions d'euros c'est ce
qu'a annoncé par premier ministre alors
qu'on vient vous en prendre 3 milliards
de l'autre côté on voit bien que le
compte n'y est pas et vous monsieur
mienne qu'en pensez vous alors d'abord
je voudrais rétablir un tout petit peu
c'est vrai que le prix des carburants a
évolué depuis mai 2010 est ça je parle
je vais pas le nier mais je voudrais
qu'on ait une idée assez précise de la
part de la fiscalité par rapport à la
part de ski et l'augmentation du baril
de pétrole parce que tout n'est pas dû à
la fiscalité
donc si vous prenez par exemple le
diesel je prends les chiffres d'octobre
2010 8 sachant qu'en novembre 2018
s'abaisser là cette semaine de trois
centimes en moyenne sur le diesel de 5
centimes sur le 95 donc on est revenu à
ce qu'on a connu avant le pic d'octobre
donc si je prends octobre le laos était
à peu près de 0 31 euro il y avait 0 11
centimes d'euro pour la fiscalité 0,20
centimes d'euro pour le prix du baril de
pétrole
parce que c'est comme en négociant
dollars ça tient aussi compte du taux de
change
et pour le sp 95 19 centimes
d'augmentation 0 0 6 centime pour pour
la taxe il y à la fiscalité 13 senti
donc 66% sur la hausse du baril de
pétrole
alors moi j'entends je suis
automobilistes aussi je prends ma
voiture tous les jours je j'entends
complètement ce que ce que vous dites
l'idée là oui on va continuer la
taxation carbone on va continuer la
taxation le premier mis cela dit on
qu'on va continuer en janvier il y aura
une nouvelle hausse je vais pas vous
mentir mais ce qu'on essaye de faire la
cdd effectivement les gens les plus
défavorisés à pouvoir accéder aux
voitures les prime à la conversion moi
j'entendais en venant sur une rade sur
une radio
quelqu'un qui disait oui mais s'ils
croient que je peux m'acheter une
voiture à 25000 euros il parlait d'une
voiture neuve
la prime à la conversion elle marche sur
les véhicules d'occasion
donc on peut monter jusqu'à 4000 euros
vous avez aussi les bonus écologiques
chez les constructeurs renault s'est
engagé à faire de l'abonnement qui peut
considérablement baisser la facture
l'idée en dehors de cette taxe
effectivement qui peut vous paraître
injuste c'est d'enclencher un phénomène
que l'on aurait déjà dû enclencher vous
avez de la mémoire je suis sûr que vous
en souvenez en 1998 puisqu'on avait
commencé enclenché le rattrapage de
détaxe du diesel sur l'essence en 98 et
s'est trouvé que deux ans après le baril
de pétrole a su à augmenter et que le
gouvernement d'alors a cédé à la
pression de la rue chacun fait ce qu'il
veut nous on essaie d'être responsable
et d'engager un mouvement global on le
fait non seulement sur les voitures
alors je sais que ça gèle les
automobilistes aujourd'hui mais on met
tout en place pour pouvoir leur
permettre de changer de véhicule
notamment en alsc en achetant des
véhicules d'occasion moins polluant que
les véhicules qu'ils ont ça c'est la
première chose jamais je crois il ya eu
autant d'efforts de fait à la prime à la
conversion que par ce gouvernement là ça
c'est première chose
deuxième chose on le fait aussi
également sur la rénovation énergétique
des bâtiments parce que vous avez vu que
on va finir par arrêter les chaudières
au fioul mais en aidant les gens à le
dispositif est pas encore au point
puisque c'est dans dix ans mais on va
étudier le dispositif se forment une
espèce de ses hits est je pense un petit
peu plus évoluée que ce qu'on a connu
tout ça c'est pour aller dans le sens
effectivement de faire baiser baisser
par mois
les gaz à effet de serre en france on le
fait de manière volontaire
conscient des difficultés mais si on
enclenche pas quelque chose de ferme
on n'y arrivera jamais or il faut qu'on
le fasse pour répondre juste quelque
chose quand vous disiez la france tout
seul dans son coin peut rien faire je
vous prends un exemple on a dit qu on
interdisait les véhicules thermiques
moi je peux véhicules thermiques en 2040
c'est bien nous qui l'avons dit
l'espagne vient de voter exactement la
même chose
arrêt des véhicules essence et diesel
pour 2040 on a été précurseur on a été
suivi donc il ya quand même un mouvement
qui en revanche et c'est bien de prendre
une décision pour 2040 vous et moi le
haut sera pas forcément là pour la voir
alors ça n'engage pas de ça n'engage pas
à grand chose sachant que la vie je veux
dire par là qu'on n'est pas les seuls à
penser ça si je reviens pas même sur les
taxes carburant parce que les taxes
carburant c'est un argumentaire
effectivement qui a été mis en place par
le gouvernement
mais il ya quand même 60% de taxes sur
les carburants quand vous regardez la
composition du prix c'est 60% et
pourquoi nous seraient parmi les plus
chers en europe
donc les gens ne comprennent pas ça le
gazole aujourd'hui c'est encore 80% de
la consommation
on a incité des gens achetaient des
diesels en se disant pour l'heure dix
ans mais vous êtes vertus aujourd'hui on
les traite de power et on vient les
pénaliser et c'est quand même pas notre
but ultime c'est progressivement
d'enlever le diesel le carburant le but
ultime c'est de se débarrasser des
concours 1 dès qu'on pourra des énergies
fossiles
il faut pas il faut pas se leurrer que
ce que alors le diesel je suis d'accord
avec vous le diesel est mis en
accusation pour les particules fines
même s'ils ont beaucoup progressé
là-dessus oui mais il en reste quand
même
aujourd'hui les particules fines émises
par les véhicules diesel dans leur
globalité en france c'est responsable de
48 mille morts par an il faut quand même
le dire anticipations mais oui les deux
conseillères du un jour de trois mois
personne qu'elle dit non
on s'est trouvés médicalement nessus on
sait tous tous lutter contre la
pollution s'est trouvée mais également
au nom de la dramatisation la solution
taxer les gens c'est insupportable et
semble complètement a terminé et les
sens et l'essence c'est le réchauffement
de la planète c'est les gaz à effet de
serre qu'il faut qu'il faut qu'il faut
bouger
juste un petit un petit point sur la tei
c'est pour être très précis sur la
répartition puisqu'on nous a fait
beaucoup de reproches en nous disant de
toute façon vous taxer mais ça pas la
transition énergétique 61% à tester le
valletta 18 % et 18 % vont aux
départements et aux régions
d'ailleurs à ce propos j'aimerais bien
que les régions et les départements nous
disent ce qu'ils font en matière de
transition énergétique
c'est bien parce que non mais attendez
quand je vois les départements des
yvelines le département dans lequel on
est mon cher monsieur dont la taxe
foncière la part départementale de la
taxe foncière a augmenté de 66% en 2016
et qui utilise cette taxe foncière pour
faire du co développement international
à hauteur de messi piqué cela à
quelqu'un qui va au boulot le matin en
province surtout qu'il doit faire
oui les moyens maintenant attendez vous
vient va les aider à changer de véhicule
le premier ni cela dit sur le
quinquennat on va changer d'un million
de véhicules
vous savez qu'on vend 5 millions de
véhicules d'occasion chaque année plus 2
millions de véhicules neufs
ça fait 7 millions qui chante qui sont
achetés chaque année cette fois 5 à 25
millions là on va faire un million ça
fait 2 8% du pas alors je suis
décidément je vous propose de voir ce
que pensent les yvelinois notamment
concernant la manifestation des gilet
jaune organisée samedi assez bien
en vo pour les gens qui ont fait cette
initiative
il se trouve que je me balade un peu
souvent à travers l'europe
mais je ne vois pas pourquoi ce que nous
avions nous avions tous au même endroit
et que chez nous ce soir beaucoup plus
cher que dans d'autres pays
alors c'était que quelque chose qui est
un peu aberrant qui est deux
augmentations certes monde en salle
signé par rapport aux pays limitrophes
on va essayer d'y participer c'est
normal oui on va essayer de montrer que
bah ouais que cette histoire ça touche
tout le monde chez les ambulanciers ça
touche les taxis ça touche les gens qui
travaillent avec leurs véhicules alors
contre moi en tant que professionnel la
route c'est vrai que faire à plein à
presque 120 euros le plein c'est vrai
que ça ça prend beaucoup de bons
bénéfices
la veille déjà trop cher alors que monte
autant de temps à passer pour ça on
travaille pour genre 1000 euros par mois
et est presque toutes là toute la paix y
va dans la voiture en fait et c'est
n'importe quoi
on a pu entendre les usagers est ce que
on peut se demander si une légère baisse
du prix du carburant suffira-t-elle à
stopper la manifestation de samedi
c'était ce qu'il suffirait d'annuler les
taxes on voit pas pourquoi on met des
taxes sur le carburant est à la hausse
vous avez eu déjà la tesi la tpp
flottant sous jospin le blocage des
carburants quand hollande et est arrivé
comme président c'était assez simple il
fallait pas construire cette usine à
gages donc finalement là on peut
expliquer ce que voulez vous avez
certainement raison dans vos chiffres
mais on peut tout expliquer vous avez
vous la réaction des gens qui sont dans
la vraie vie
alors on pourrait dire je suis le
médecin ce sont mes malades j'arrive pas
à l'égaler que ce sont de mauvais
malades
posez vous la question si vous êtes un
bon maintien là bas alors moi je crois
qu on est des bons médecins ces deux là
toute la différence entre nous deux dans
ce que je veux dire par là c'est que là
ce qu'on met en place ce qui va être mis
en place d'ailleurs cette semaine à
partir de jeudi-vendredi puisque il ya
de nouveaux amendements qui vont arriver
et sûrement des amendements
gouvernementaux sur les mesures que le
premier ministre a annoncé ce matin
nous on va emporter d'autres notamment
une aide à l'installation des boîtiers
électroniques sur les voitures essence
pour le bioéthanol ça une aide là dessus
si ça acceptés par le gouvernement
c'est un grand plus pour les
automobilistes qui roulent à l'essence
et puisque quand même le litres de
bioéthanol est à 70 centimes d'euro donc
ça fait quand même une grosse différence
bon l'idée c'est l'idée maintenant c'est
qu'on a plus le temps nous on n'avait
pas prévu
personne n'avait prévu même pas les
climatologues l'accélération presque
exponentielle
j'aime pas le réchauffement tati
climatique mais du changement climatique
si on ne fait rien maintenant si on ne
fait rien maintenant on court à la
catastrophe
alors l'été comme vous le disiez tout à
l'heure ni vous ni moi ni vous ni moi ne
seront là pour l'avoir à la catastrophe
mais peut-être que mes petits-enfants
face à la hausse du carburant à ce que
les véhicules électriques sont une
alternative
alors moi je suis un petit peu plus
réservé là dessus les véhicules
électriques c'est la technologie la plus
avancée qu'on est aujourd'hui dans le
zéro émission de co2 zéro émissions de
particules
ça c'est la définition pour moi du
véhicule électrique aujourd'hui je
préfère l'hybride pour être honnête
parce que véhicule électrique pose
d'autres questions même si on est en
train de construire en europe un espèce
de co2
deux sociétés européennes basées sur la
société saft qui fait débat la grille
pour faire des batteries européenne et
arrêter d'importer ses batteries d'asile
d'un tavares par exemple celles se dire
finalement ce qui domine le marché des
batteries le joli ce sont les chinois
donc demain les chinois vont racheter
nos constructeurs ou des dépendants des
terres rares de chine c'est bien lithium
le lithium on en a assez bien for sale
c'est bien pour ça que je vous amène une
réponse à la donc là les l'autre réponse
que je vais demander aux constructeurs
automobiles l'autre demande que je fais
au constructeur automobile parce que
voient pas ou quand même oublié de nos
constructeurs automobiles n'y a pas si
loin de ça vous les automobilistes c'est
vous qui les avez sauvé avec quoi avec
vos impôts qui sauvait de sa wii donc
j'aimerais qu'ils nous apportent une
réponse maintenant et matière de
recherche et développement il y en a une
sur laquelle jouent mais sur laquelle je
crois mais que pour la scène et sur
laquelle les l'hydrogène ils devraient
ils devraient s'y mettre et les états
sont là pour effectivement faire en
sorte d'établir des normes mais méfiez
vous avec la fiche qualité d'un site est
allé vers hôtels motels technologie on a
incité les gens à lire le diésel
je suis pas d'enjeu quelques années
j'avais moi je fais beaucoup de débats
avec des écologistes vous allez madame
limousin d'action pour le climat qui me
disaient mais monsieur quand il rappelle
des voitures électriques vous savez que
les moteurs xaml des champs magnétiques
dont j'aurai des milliers de voitures
dans la rue qui vivent des champs
magnétiques les champs magnétiques donne
le cancer donc oui vous avez des centres
écologique et pour qui la mobilité c'est
des transports en commun le vélo la
marche à pied il faut faire attention
l'électrique tout le monde la viande à
dire que à la fin des années 2000
25 de 80 il y aura peut-être un
pourcentage d'électrique pas plus et en
2015 c'est pas mon nom sera fiable pour
ça je vous dis que il n'y a pas qu'une
seule recherche sur laquelle il faut
aller et que les laiteries n'est pas
forcément l'alpha et l'oméga
il faut aller sur l'hydrogène il faut
privilégier pendant cette transition
industrielle parce que le problème il
est où
c'est que la transition industrielle n'a
pas été fait pour l'instant si la
transition industrielle avait été fait
on n'en serait pas là tous les deux pour
on parle c'est vrai donc il faut pousser
aussi sur le quotidien est là
aujourd'hui et garderont le prix niel le
quotidien il est là je vous pose plus et
ça se rajoutent ciblées ont en début de
semaine vous annoncer qu'on attire des
700 mille véhicules de rouler en
cependant voilà après deux jours avant
vous annoncer l'augmentation de deux des
autoroutes de manière considérable
vous avez le 4e kilomètre je te brise ne
peut plus donc c'est la goutte de gasoil
qui a fait déborder le réservoir
on arrive à la fin de ce débat je vous
propose messieurs de conclure chacun en
une minute ou la wii by concédé nous
c'est assez simple vous avez vu les
automobilistes vu ce qu'ils demandent
ils demandent finalement à pouvoir
rouler avoir gardé leur pouvoir de
rouler on a été augmentée les carburants
au nom de de la transition énergétique
pourquoi ce n'est pas la même chose
partout en europe on est largement au
dessus
donc plutôt que d'essayer de monter des
usines à gaz pour redonner avec des gens
qui ne comprennent pas trop grand chose
il était aussi simple d'annuler cette
augmentation est il faut pas rêver
pourquoi on serait plus remonté que les
autres pays c'est ce que disent les gens
c'est tout simple la vraie vie c'est ça
sinon moi je veux dire aux gens que 1
tous les tous les carburants vont
augmenter en europe
quoi que l'on en pense ça c'est la
première chose parce que le mouvement
est enclenché
il ne s'arrêtera pas parce que il ya une
planète à sauver contrairement à ce que
peuvent croire les gens ça joue la
voiture ça joue là dessus que oui il
faut aller sur des d'autre alternative
que l'électrique il faut aller en
recherche et développement partout à la
fois sur les biocarburants à la fois sur
l'hydrogène sur ces connaît aujourd'hui
mais folie's faut essayer de travailler
sur d'autres choses et que oui on fait
le maximum sur les mesures qui ont été
proposées par gouvernement et on aura
deux proposés par les députés pour
adoucir cette transition qui est
compliquée et qui forcément sera cher et
compliqué pour tout le monde mais il
faut qu'on y aille
c'est l'avis de nos arrières petits
enfants ou petits enfants qui en dépend
merci à vous deux d'être venu pour ce
débat c'est la fin de ce sept huit
débats on se retrouve mercredi prochain
très bonne soirée sur tv 78
[Musique]